I've never I've never ever ever had this
much fun making a movie it was very very
hard don't get me wrong but I I always
always every day I woke up eager to go
to work I discovered myself smiling
several times a week like like like
enjoying it and I and I I truly truly
wanted to him it's very difficult to
explain in other ways but it's an
incredibly complex movie that I one of
the biggest complexities was to keep it
simple you know I really wanted to I
wanted I made this movie for me at age
11 and and for any kid no matter what
your age is bodily you know your bodily
age is like 11 years old and I really
think that many of the movies now I
always tried to over neuro ties and
psychoanalyze and go existential on pop
themes and I wanted to sort of show kids
effortless heroism and do it in a way
that is not dependent on one ideology
one country or a veil assist thing like
I wanted them to be the resistance I
wanted them to be from every country
from every race creed color and so on
and so forth and but I wanted to keep it
really almost the arc of one character
is the arc of all the characters I can I
elaborate on that a little bit because
what I didn't wanted one guy saving the
whole world all on his own I certainly
didn't want all the aliens in every
movie they get one map that points to
New York you know and and I wanted to
show inverter where are you ever wear
the bread basket and they really they
really I wanted to to have it one of
them the movie that inspired me we were
talking about it on the wings are the
weird the weirdest references aside from
Cairo and makin I got a lot of
inspiration from Spore
smoothies I I was like watching whose
ears friday night lied you know the the
miracle i was watching sports movies
because i thought the analogy for me was
a guy that was out of the game for five
years and was coming back after an
injury this is rocky three it was well
he certainly the Russians looked like
Dolph I just think I wanted to allow
this movie to exist in a plane were kids
to they could enjoy the way I enjoyed
them the giant kaiju movies when I was a
kid which is a using every technical
tool to my advantage to you to really
make them believe in the size of the
monsters which in itself is a very
complex exercise but also I wanted them
to be able to enjoy it without having to
have a what I think is a negative moral
repercussion where where I think you can
see the movie and the scale for example
is so exaggerated and so peppered with
comedy and so void of victims I made it
a point that I never wanted victory I
need they didn't want to have people on
the street or in a boss or in a car that
we could really just do this the joy
that you had as a kid when you knew they
were modeled as a kid but here to look
real but not to be worrying oh that's a
fun sequence where 300 people just got
crushed of course yeah the exhilaration
feel guilty because also Chi juice are
beautiful because you don't feel there
is any repercussions in the real world
there's no chance a kaiju in Oklahoma is
going to watch the movie and go out and
try to destroy a shopping mall we have a
relationship with technology in the West
that is guilty we always think of
technology like Frankenstein he's going
to ultimately it'll turn against us you
know the Japanese just love technology
they truly love it and and the mecca is
a celebration of this technology
building gigantic warriors basically
from heaven mythological size warriors
and the and that's how I look at the
jaegers
I am 48 executing the movie I'm 11
looking at the movie and they don't have
this guilt with the monsters with the
kaiju to answer your question with the
kaiju ever there is in Japan there was
such a bonding with the chi-you
partially because Japan has always
integrated the sort of magical and
mythological in their culture through
the yokai and through you know there's
always a living entity and everything
and everything has a guardian an
elemental guardian and Godzilla came in
the first try was to make him a terrible
terrible monster partially modeled after
the idea the the dynamics of Kong or Ray
Harryhausen's beast you know and so on
as what and then eventually what
resulted is that this creature helped
heal the wounds from World War two and
it became an elemental guardian of Japan
and from then on in a kaiju movie it
doesn't matter if the kaiju is good or
bad you love them all obviously this is
a science fiction generically would be
science fiction but you're very right
that visually I pleaded like a fantasy I
decidedly made that make the point of
not treating it like a super polish
sci-fi fluorescent night high-tech cool
looking sexy machines I went I'm going
to treat it like a fantasy film to the
point where the memory of Michael for me
is a little princess being saved from a
dragon by a knight in shining armor and
that's the way I tried to put an almost
poetic little spirit in that in that
memory and the fantasy colors and the
one guy do is like a dragon almost and
so on and so forth so you know for me
fantasy has a visual coding and then it
has a literary or thematic coding those
are two different things so Thea
matically this would be in theory
science fiction I'm more interested in
the function and in the science
evidently but but so all I need to see
my storytelling the pain
very much a once upon a time where I say
once upon a time there was a rift in the
ocean that that cook you to another
dimension that's it